To explain the difference between child protection and
child safeguarding, um, it's actually very complicated
often because in so many languages, we don't have a
word for safeguarding, but what we kind of do on a
European level what the Council of Europe does, the
European union and the UN, UNICEF, we've all kind
of established  safeguarding as kind of an internal
structure, whilst protection is more external.
So when we're talking about protection, we talk
about the systems, the, their structures around
kind of anything that has to do with, with the
country or with the institutions in the country
and so on, how we protect the children from harm.
But when we talk about safeguarding, we look inside
ourselves and we look inside our organization and we
say, how are we making sure that in anything that we do
within our organization, we're keeping children safe.
So when we talk about why safeguarding is
so important, it is mainly because so many
people do wrong by not knowing better.
So a lot of safeguarding breaches that happen simply
happened because people haven't been taught and they
haven't been taught to think in a certain direction
and think about the consequences of their actions.
So small things that you might consider to be minimal
might actually be bigger in, in, in the big context.
And these are very often things that might seem very
straightforward, but aren't, and just getting that
kind of notion into people's head about how we save our
children and how we make sure that in our interaction,
um, we are always putting the benefit of the child
first.
This also escalates within the individuals.
So as soon as you start this process and start this thought,
people then can kind of follow it themselves as well.